[Music]
okay hello do you hear me
remove all okay cool so thanks very much
and yeah welcome to my presentation
where I'm going to talk about like a few
trade offs that we take when building
products that use a lots of data which
is machine learning models okay just get
you some context about about where we do
it so whatever is the largest e-commerce
platform important we have roughly 60
million active offers listed on the
platform and for the data volume it's
it's it's around number CC so almost
three terabytes of daily data increment
and and young cluster two to handle debt
and all the processing of it okay one
disclaimer it's everything presented
here is is a come on come on work of
many people from from our company okay
so in then I'm talking about it in a few
contexts that we use parts of the parts
of the things that I'm going to present
to build products like like you see
there life products on our platform for
search relevancies suggestions
evaluation of those products and those
those are typical use cases and it's
just the tech stack around nothing for
in your fancy ok so first of all I want
to talk about one trade of that we that
we need to consider when building data
pipelines even jobs that process data
however we we work on it is it's more
about how we what's our process of
working with it whether we start and
think from the real data or we look at
it from more engineering perspective and
do it like it's done in any other
software
which is usually it's test driven so
what I mean by this I mean like
data-driven approach would be to
straight straight right into the data
you you need to work on and just you
know experiment work work on it until
you get an expected outcome it's like
maybe the most natural way for for many
people just to do like this and by
test-driven approach I mean to gather
some static probably sample of the data
get a test for it specified the expected
output I meant it and only then after we
have it ready in like an really isolated
environment run it on production data of
course those are very extreme versions
of those approaches will come maybe do
some thing in the middle in a while so
of course it's with the data-driven
approach is really easier to start to
it's interactive so it's easy for you to
you don't need to have a full idea and
your head when starting I have a really
short feedback loop when you when it's
like this part with test-driven approach
it's Charlie best practice because you
sure it works as expected
afterwards you have a safe safety having
a regression suit around but it's
actually harder to set up especially at
the beginning it's hard to get
everything around so that it really
works as as it should ok so I should
have put some fancy funny image from the
internet here why not both yeah so if I
could keep my notebook as it is in
version control with test it around
run it on a schedule with some control
around it why not like this and it's
possible actually we'll do it in some in
a few projects so we keep notebooks are
actually kept in version control as a
simple Python files they are converted
back to the notebook format and
always on some running Jupiter and only
one need to want to work on it you can
either go this way so yeah okay it's
just a project so I can write the test
implemented in the idea push it to the
version control or I can actually look
at the notebook itself and work with it
in an interactive way and only after
that I did to like if I want to keep the
testing coverage for for this for my
change I need to like go back one step
after I know what I want to do and make
it put it in the in the source control
so it always goes back to the single
point of true so which is the source
control with Python files and and then
it can go as well for the code review
process which is kind of hard if you
just have for example keep some
notebooks it's not that easy
there is no good tooling around code
review own interpreter notebooks or at
least we don't know yeah so just one
example of it how do we test pipe spark
jobs so as we heard on the previous talk
we as well use docker here we have an
image with Python spark that gives us
the principal environment and the scanf
usually tests are like the end-to-end
tests like Marcel said we as well or at
least I prefer them they give you
assurance that everything works not just
some small parts so we typically mimic
the storage as file system boots and
data right to test - to execute the job
and verify that it actually did what we
want it yeah it's run on our machine and
on continuous integration as well okay
well there are other building blocks
well to have it your notebook must be
parametrized but providing high default
values so that it can be both run on on
schedule with some specific parameters
but as well allow you to stay safe
when working on it with it interactively
in Iran as a whole it should be
idempotence meaning that if I run it
twice or multiple times the result is
the same
we need version control test deployment
these are stuff that as well Marshall
talked about a bit what I want to
highlight here is that it's actually
after we have some metrics we it's
usually good to set up some monitoring
around the process even if it at least
check the dataset size that you don't
get an empty data set or a really small
data set when you didn't expect it and
stop the process maybe okay mmm another
trade-off I had recently an occasion to
compare pies park with like traditionals
Park jobs within Scala and actually hard
to tell which one is better
it depends you well for sure if you if
you write it in sky you have better
ideas support its it will fit if you
have if you expect the project to be
complex so if you expect to do some a
lot of engineering work then you have
refactoring credi
cetera and you have at least some level
type safety for sure everywhere in the
like classic Scala
code but as well with the using the new
API of datasets which is almost always
typesafe with regard to the data column
that you process are the almost I will
maybe show in a moment what I mean about
that but umpires park is for sure easier
for non developers to grasp and
sometimes it makes job like more concise
it's the data frame API is easier to
mutate on it adds of columns which is
not that simple if you go with the Scala
version so one example is the joint
sorry duty calls from the top is
Scala snippets from one of our jobs and
you see it's quite interesting
those underscore one underscore one or
in a way to handle how joy wave is
implemented in Scala spark and because
it gives you actually structure of a
structure of a structure and as you can
see the names of the columns types of
the columns are not actually type text
yeah just strings see what will happen
the last part after the map is just to
get the structure back to the flat flat
data set format while in a traditional
in a data frame API for example in
Python on the bottom you would just get
a it's it's it's more stream like you
would get an A flat data frame after
after that okay so this was like the
first part of my talk in a second I
would like to talk about how we put that
put all this up into schedule into a
manageable system that works every day
every hour and here I want to talk about
Apache airflow in in some more detail we
use it quite extensively right now so
this is an mmm workflow scheduler it can
execute your process that you define at
an at your schedule and it will handle
dependencies it will handle quite a lot
of things and everything is specified
which is really great as a Python code
it's culturally Python DSL where you
specify what should be done afterwards
and and actually everything so if you
want to do any any fancy logic or you
need to loop you need to build three
models you just can write a loop the
rent you don't have any problem that on
the right you see a screen of one of the
executions of the dogs and you see this
red thingy failed at that point so the
to the right is yellow or orange it
means that well actually it couldn't run
it because it has missing dependencies
so it really makes managing and
understanding what happened quite easy
what we have there in our flow we have
operators which mean do something it's
typically from the simplest Bosch
operator where you can put anything to
operators handling HDFS handling hive
queries anding quite a lot of things we
have sensors that we can write our it
here so that waits for something maybe
wait for some data that is an input to
your next step maybe wait ask some
system above about something can wait
for it we can provide variables at
runtime to configure like you're running
jobs we have pools which is something
that you can ensure that there are not
many not more than and processes pushes
for example data to your database
because it would crush but you want to
run them in and you don't want to put
them sequentially because for example
they have different dependencies
yeah branching logic and there is a lot
of integrations with a duplicate system
with Amazon various databases like
available in the air flow itself parts
from which you can write their execution
control gives you a verse monitoring you
can get notified when something failed
of course it can retry I think before it
says it's narrow you can specify timeout
so that some process will not hang for
more than one hour it will just fail
after the time if it didn't finish
successfully you can view investigate
the duration of your tasks in in time
for example to see if they do not grow
it might be a bad sign
okay nothing comes without a price to
pay
it's actually free and open source
system it's it's very good but it has
its quirks
would call it and that's why there are
at least some resources that specify
those pitfalls so if you are to try with
it just read those even before you read
the whole documentation because it may
save you just one one day or if you had
scratches it's quite major although its
use form by more than 100 companies as I
looked at at the github so we use it at
least in a few projects here yeah and
maintaining it is actually quite easy
but I understand that for Tim said for
example don't want to focus on technical
stuff at all like not having any
engineering perspective it would be even
easier not maintaining it at all that's
why we are exploring internally an
airflow as a service where each team
would be able to just you know click
itself and set up a new airflow instance
that's actually because air flow cannot
be used as a as have any multi-tenancy
support so you cannot use it you cannot
use one instance by different teams that
are not sharing they or their code and
there's a quite a neat idea we didn't
explore fully that it's a DSL but you
can make a build-your-own DSL on top of
it so if you have a some companies
facing companies specific things or
project specific tool services you can
have someone to like write dedicated
operators sensors for it and every team
will just use those building blocks just
to write like on a higher abstraction
level write their definitions of their
jobs these ducts I think I didn't
explain it it's just the whole graph of
execution is called direct acyclic graph
yes it's it's quite powerful
okay some alternatives well actually you
can get crawl which is just basic
scheduling nothing else where's Suzy
which is part of some distributions
already so it's hard to do something
more complex with it it's hard to
maintain because either you click in the
GUI everything and then it's lost if it
crashes or you don't have any versioning
already used in XML which is not very
which is not very nice and there's Luigi
which it's the most similar to airflow
but it doesn't have scheduler built in
it's quite slow it's slower than air
flow for large graphs of dependencies it
doesn't have that many features not
going into every detail they are a bit
different in a way how they handle our
dependencies so Luigi is more like
output oriented which means that it
expects every task to produce some state
that can be checked for example a file
somewhere and it then checks if this
file is ready
while the airflow is just using its own
database to to know which task was
already executed which tasks failed etc
etc so yeah but there are alternatives
mmm ok and mmm I guess that's it it took
really I didn't use the whole half an
hour so I guess I'm more open to
questions before like very tiring you
feel like building such things you're
looking for data scientist software
engineer so we are to have four
questions starting with the first one
from the back
because you're talking about the Jupiter
notebook in the beginning and some of
the functionalities you like added to it
have you considered using chaplain
notebooks and and Eve s if you did some
comparison for your we tried to pull him
but it was quite a lot long time ago I
didn't do any comparison recently we've
heard it's it's used and a few people
prefer it because it's not like gold
standard and a whole company but
unfortunately I cannot give you my
personal comparison next one in the back
go from the back was versatile so do you
think it's easy to pick up for a team of
data scientists only or do you think
they would probably need some engineers
to set it up for them as well you mean
to set up an airflow and since I think
it's it's possible if at least someone
already do some is doing some hacking
with with bar scripts or with some
system integration that is it's doable
it's getting really Stabler and Stabler
with each version it used to be another
thing that I would recommend but right
now I think it's it's doable maybe with
some very small support at the beginning
my question is flowy like that so do you
have any failover strategy like a
cluster of flow instances if one fails
and everyone can pick up the job yeah
well in the in the scenario where we're
going to have it like an airflow as a
service and it will be deployed in an
isolated way when in docker container
messes then it will be quite easy to do
it because we can just scale it up and
it integrates for the database which
then will be just a single point of
failure probably I mean not sure if
there's like the
[Music]
yes and but currently we just used on in
a few places just in one on one machine
if you have some monitoring that works
as is that if the effects of jobs are
not there somewhere and you get notified
you can catch that up yes because you
cannot monitor air flow from inside air
flow in this scenario but we actually
never happened to do well we never
happen to have it like down because of
the machine but yes having it in a high
availability would be the way to go if
you okay one more all right so thank you
so much for your talk thank you
[Applause]
you